Selena Gomez cheers on Justin Bieber at  his hockey game and leaves wearing his  jersey the exes were spotted together on  Wednesday night at the Los Angeles  Valley Ice Center in Ventura California  the wolf singer attended Beavers game  wearing black pants and a matching top  with a jean jacket but she left the rink  wearing Bieber's red jersey as she got  into his car the two have yet to comment  on the current status of their  relationship but a source close to the  stars tells et that while they aren't  officially together it's heading in that  direction quote this shouldn't even be  considered getting back together it's  really a brand new relationship they are  both different people and their  relationship now is completely different  you